I understand you went to the ER you went
to a birthday March there were many how
was the Earth Day March it was good you
guys a fan of Earth and two rounds yeah
thirds water boom I marched and there
was it wasn't your typical like
dreadlock II protest Eve I've you know
there were doctors with lab coats on and
stuff it was really inspirational but
then you're marching and you're thinking
like why are we marching why do we have
to march for science why is this
when did science become politicized you
know I mean like like it's just it's
facts like pretty soon my kid is gonna
be like in his third great I don't have
one yet but I'm planning I thought and
like he's gonna be in like a third grade
class putting the baking soda vinegar
volcano and some other six-year-old to
be like not in my America [ __ ] you know
I don't think that's gonna happen but
yeah you're right yeah you're there it's
very strange time but you think it was
at least a positive sign though that so
many people turned out for the Earth Day
it was good it was good
I mean it was good until I went back the
next day cuz my hotel was right where
the March had happened right and I went
back to where the Earth Day March had
happened there was Earth Day litter
everywhere it was so hilarious it was
like the pro-environment litter just
like I mean it basically made me realize
like if every day was Earth Day it would
make absolutely no difference we are
screwed dude yeah yeah yeah it would you
just excuse to litter yeah
you